let's get the latest on events in
Westminster it's not even a month and a
half since the last Tory leadership
election came to an end and yet there's
already talk of another the rules for
such a contest are governed by the 1922
committee as things currently stand the
conservative party leader cannot be
challenged in the first year of their
tenure but with disquiet already growing
among Tory backbenchers could that
change well considered MP for reingate
Crispin blunt joins me now good to see
you this evening do you think Liz truss
needs to go
I'm afraid they're blindly obvious
conclusion is that she must uh not least
in her own interests but most
importantly for the government to be
able to carry credibility and to be able
to bring the conservative party uh
together to get us back in place where
we can deliver sound finance and sound
Administration and make sure that the
alternative proposition of the labor
party who plainly odds on favorites now
uh for the next election that there is a
proper opportunity to examine that over
the next two years and to flesh out
other propositions they've got which at
the moment look fiscally rather like the
propositions Liz truss and Crosby
cartoon before that have come such a
Cropper
despite a new Chancellor despite those
u-turns you can't see how she can
survive
no I don't not when the principal
emotions of people watching her doing
her best to present is some combination
of pity contempt or anger uh I'm afraid
it just won't wash and we need to make a
change
you're the first Tory mp2 break cover
publicly and say she must go do you know
of more who are prepared to do the same
uh certainly I've had since I started to
uh League out this afternoon I've been a
number of colleagues who have uh
encouragement in what I'm in what I'm
saying it is a blinding MC office we all
know this
the papers of course today full of talk
of of plots to
oust the prime minister is that your
understanding lots of plots underway at
the moment
um I'm not part of any uh plots I'm just
making uh uh this observation which does
strike me as uh blindingly obvious but
someone has to say it first uh and the
my colleagues who are being interviewed
this morning on the media uh were faced
with the obvious conclusion but simply
wouldn't say it uh we do now need to get
on and pull our party together uh for
the interests of our country
um so that we can actually get back to a
government that has the confidence of
the people confidence of the markets and
most importantly gives the opportunity
to put the alternative proposition uh
under proper examination and for the
labor party to have to address the
detail in their proposition that should
then mean that in two years time we have
a proper contest between the two parties
for the governance of the country you
don't think it would be fairer to wait
until the end of the month when we hear
once again from the new Chancellor he
sets out his stall and perhaps the
Market's a Karma well I think Jeremy
Hunt arriving in the government is very
welcome indeed but it's an insufficient
uh part of the presentations in the
country uh to just have the chancellor
who carries confidence we need to have
uh confidence uh at the top at the at
the very top and I fear uh that Liz
trust uh now is almost impossible for
her to carry that conference either with
her colleagues at all with the country
and certainly not with uh the
examination she's going to get from the
media
how would this happen the rules say that
she's safe for 12 months don't they
that's the that's the formal position
but we all uh understand the The Wider
positions we all have a responsibility
uh for a good government and at least
trustful feels just as much as anyone
else uh if the issue does have to be
forced a way can be found uh to force it
uh that was shown when Boris Johnson
lost the Confluence of his uh
ministerial colleagues uh now I wasn't
part of that and perhaps some of the
problem we're dealing with now is the
Fallout from that but we've now got to
get on uh and deliver uh government of
the country in which people can be
confident but can the party uh indeed
come the public tolerate a third prime
minister in as many months on top of a
fourth Chancellor in four months uh yes
if it's going to improve the
presentation of the government and the
administration of the government and
plenty it will
so who would you like to take over
for me uh the obvious choice uh now that
Jeremy Hunt has become the chancellor uh
that a triumvirate between him Rishi
sunak and Penny Mortons and I think
Rishi is more suited to the prime
ministerial role
um uh Penny Morton has huge thanks in
presentation in uh assisting both Rishi
and Jeremy in making a presentation as a
country in which people can have
confidence and uh so my preference would
be Richie sunak who did have the most
support in the Parliamentary party in
the leadership election and his warnings
now see impressions
the membership don't want him though do
they or certainly they didn't vote for
him I think the membership as the
contest developed you could see that
Rishi was gaining uh on Liz trust in the
contest but he began with the
handicapper being associated with uh the
all the scores of ministers who uh
resigned uh in order to try and leave a
Boris out of the position as as prime
minister and Morris is very popular with
the members um he's very popular with me
um uh but you know the herd mood as he
just described it and if he hadn't had
to carry that particular burden I think
he would have won the contest with Liz
very comfortably indeed uh well we're
now in that position uh he has a
confidence of colleagues for a reason
he's a very talented man and in my
general it was always going to be a
prime minister someday from the moment I
first said eyes on him when he arrived
in Parliament after election in Richmond
in 2015. uh we're lucky to have him in
politics yeah and very briefly if you
can um if Liz truss is to go how quickly
could this potentially happen
um the pace needs to be decided by the
1922 executive and the committee
collectively and also the contextual the
national Union as well as all the key
players in this uh uh which includes
trust but they also include uh the
senior leaders uh that I've mentioned
and I hope they will pick up their
responsibility to deliver government of
our country in which we can be confident
okay uh we appreciate your time we must
leave it there Crispin blunt MP thank
you